in this week's morning rounds an
intimate look at the devastating
progression of Alzheimer's disease
according to the Alzheimer's Association
every 65 seconds someone in the u.s.
develops the disease the most common
form of dementia in a remarkable report
airing on 60 minutes tomorrow night
CBS News chief medical correspondent dr.
Jon LaPook followed one patient and her
caregiver husband for a decade to give
an unprecedented look at this
debilitating condition and dr. John Ruth
joins us now with a preview good morning
good morning Dana in 2008 I first met
Carol Daly who has Alzheimer's and her
husband Mike a retired New York City cop
over the years I visited them six times
for the CBS Evening News
and this January I returned with 60
minutes to see how they were doing we
pieced it all together to give a unique
look at the toll the disease takes on
both the patient and the caregiver when
you heard the word Alzheimer's what did
that do T is devastated what makes this
story so unusual is that almost every
year for the past 10 years we've
interviewed Mike and Carol as
Alzheimer's took over her brain even
though this is intensely personal they
wanted all of us to see the devastating
impact of Alzheimer's on each of them
over a decade what's your husband's name
yeah the guy sitting to you
it's just devastating you said it I mean
you said to us in the break people have
responded on Twitter already saying this
is hard to look at and I don't know but
we have to deal with this because this
is hitting an overwhelming number of
people it's are we ready to deal with
those numbers no we're not we're not
ready for it we're not ready for it
right now I mean there's five and a half
million or so people with Alzheimer's
for every one person with Alzheimer's is
it at what ten other people who are
deeply affected it's costing hundreds of
billions of dollars in direct costs of
hundreds of billions of dollars and loss
of income from caregivers who have to
quit their jobs that help take care of
them let's talk about that because her
Carol's husband Mike becomes her
caregiver absolutely and this runs for
ten years now which is which is
extraordinary what what is the toll on
Mike over this period of time mentally
and physically it takes a huge toll on
him I mean he's so lovely he's a looking
sickness and this is what I signed up
for yeah and you see him combing her
hair and putting makeup on her and
making the beds and he said look just
the roles are reverse you used to do
this and I signed up for this he said
I'm not gonna put her in a nursing home
you know I can take care of it but he
couldn't take care of it and over the
years his blood pressure went up his
weight went up you know he became
anxious he had panic attacks and it got
to the point where he just simply
couldn't do it and I think I think
that's a lesson for this is a big
message you may think you're tough you
know he's a Staten Island cop regardin
york city cop tough as nails until
alzheimer's you cannot do it alone and
that's sort of a message that everybody
has to take away from this I think it is
and you know he had some help first of
all dr. Gayatri Devi is his neurologist
image she has been unbelievable you know
your your physician but then you sort of
cross over into friend also she's been
both of that to both of them
I find that same friction yeah I have
the physician hat I have the journalist
hat I have the person hat and you know
over ten years you become friendly with
these I was struck by that number ten
years that's a long time for an
Alzheimer's patient isn't it it is and
the Alzheimer's Association told us they
don't know of another report where
somebody was followed with Alzheimer's
and certainly in their caregiver for ten
years I know the average time that
between diagnosis and dying is about
four to eight years it can go as long as
as 20 years
there's a spectrum as dr. Devi just
wrote the Newland Journal are we just
diagnosing Alzheimer's earlier now is
that part of this or this just happens
to be a unique I think in her case it's
very unusual that she lived as long I
was just talking to dr. Devi this
morning she said she was surprised that
she lived this longer but you know there
there is hope I mean there are new
approaches to diagnosis and one of the
big things is that we think that we're
we're treating people probably way too
late that's like giving somebody lipitor
after their fifth heart attack and
they're already in heart failure you got
a it turns out that the the problems
inside the brain the pathological
changes start 10 20 30 years before the
symptoms even start and the other thing
I want to point out is people have to
have discussions when they're still with
it about what their desires are if I get
to the point where or I have to be in a
in a nursing home is that ok you know if
you can't handle me alone if I become
demented or otherwise infirmed
then is it okay to bring in outside help
I mean that is so important there are
tough discussions and Americans don't
like to have those discussions at that
end of life we have to do it dr. Jon
LaPook thank you very much and you can
see all of John's report and more
tomorrow night on 60 minutes right here
on CBS